Marvel has taken the world by storm with their
ever-expanding Marvel Cinematic Universe.
The movies, for the most part, have been great
and it is clear that countless hours of work
have gone into the creation of each one.
But all work and no play is no fun and it
seems like the people behind the scenes of
these blockbuster hits feel the same way as
bloopers and gag reels have shown the world
just how fun shooting these movies can be.
For this video we are taking a look at some
of the best for our list of 10 Marvel Superhero
Movie Bloopers That Show Popular Actors Having
Fun! Enjoy this video and be sure to hit that
subscribe button for more awesome Screen Rant
content, every single day!
Captain America Civil War
Captain America: Civil War was one of the
biggest blockbuster movies that the world
has ever seen.
With such an enormous and amazing cast, we
can guarantee that being on set for the making
of this film must have been seriously fun.
The gag reel from Civil War definitely backs
this up as it shows members of the cast constantly
cracking up or dancing around between takes.
One particularly funny moment comes when Vision,
played by Paul Bettany, is trying to deliver
a somewhat serious line but unfortunately
he keeps jumbling up the words.
He takes a second try at the line, but the
result is no better.
He and everyone around him start to laugh
showing off how well this star-studded cast
really got along.
X-Men – Days Of Future Past
We aren’t quite sure why, but it seems like
playing a Marvel movie character makes actors
always want to dance around as the X-Men Days
Of Future Past gag reel showcases a lot of
the casts best moves.
From Magneto to Quicksilver, everyone seems
to be getting down between takes and it definitely
looks like they are having a good a lot of
fun.
While the dancing could have probably ruined
some of the more serious and intense scenes,
we think that some of it could have been placed
strategically to add some funny quirks to
some of the characters.
At this point, we aren’t really sure what
direction the franchise is heading, but one
thing is for sure, wherever it goes – there
will be dancing!
Guardians Of The Galaxy
With media buzz starting to pick up for 2017’s
hotly anticipated Guardians Of The Galaxy
2, we thought it was only appropriate to reflect
on a great blooper from the original movie
that shows how fun it really was to be a part
of this movie.
Fans of Parks and Recreation already know
that Chris Pratt is a hilarious dude and a
lot of his funny quirks and lines made it
into the final cut of Guardians.
One blooper that was left out came when Pratt
was flying his ship and started laughing maniacally.
While it was funny, it was a bit too over
the top for this film but it is definitely
worth checking out on the gag reel.
Chris Pratt is amazing in the franchise and
is one of main reasons that Marvel’s Guardians
Of The Galaxy was such a cosmic hit!
Iron Man 3
Iron Man is the hero that really sent the
world into the superhero movie craze that
it’s in today.
Robert Downey Jr. is amazing in the titular
role and he totally redefined what it meant
to be a superhero.
Over the years we have seen many clips of
how fun and ridiculous RDJ is to work with
on set, but what about a funny blooper from
his Iron Man costars.
During the filming of Iron Man 3, there was
a scene where RDJ and Don Cheadle were making
Ben Kingsley make some undercover phone calls.
Kingsley needed to disguise his voice and
this led to a great gag reel moment that had
Cheadle throwing out different dialects for
Kingsley to try to do.
The moment is genuine and hilarious and does
a great job of showing off how fun it was
to be a part of this blockbuster hit.
Daredevil
2003’s Daredevil is probably one of the
worst Marvel movie adaptations of all time
and we are thankful that Netflix has now done
the great comic book character justice in
their online series.
As bad as the movie was, it still looks like
it was fun to be on set for its creation as
there are numerous gag reel moments that show
off Ben Affleck and his co-stars having a
good time.
One particularly funny blooper comes when
Colin Farrell, who plays Bullseye in the film,
swoops into the shot on a harness.
For some reason, he totally breaks character
and shows a big goofy smile.
Not stopping there, Farrell then begins to
recite and act out the Lion’s lines from
The Wizard Of Oz.
It’s probably not a good sign when your
blooper reel is more entertaining than your
actual movie, but at least it looks like the
actors behind Daredevil had fun.
Deadpool
Deadpool was one of the biggest surprise hits
of 2016 and many movie critics are placing
it high on their lists for best films of the
year.
The action was great and the story was a lot
of fun but it was really the sly R rated comedy
that sets this movie apart.
While Ryan Reynolds delivered most of the
most memorable lines, the outtakes to the
movie showcase just how funny long time comedian
TJ Miller really is.
The gag reel shows Miller delivering line
after line of hilarious descriptions of what
Deadpool looks like after the surgery.
The final cut of the film only included one
of these lines, which is unfortunate because
TJ Miller came up with some absolute zingers.
Ant-Man
When you take a ridiculous comedian and brilliant
improviser like Paul Rudd and make him a superhero,
you are bound to have some hilarious behind
the scenes moments.
This was definitely the case when it came
to filming 2015’s Ant-Man.
As with a lot of other Marvel movies, the
gag reel showcases the stars dancing around
a lot and really having a good time between
takes.
There is on blooper from Ant Man that takes
the cake though and that comes when Paul Rudd
realizes that he has just sworn with child
actor Abby Ryder Fortson in his arms.
The best part is that the scene totally breaks
down when Abby calls out Rudd for saying a
bad word and the whole crew starts laughing.
It is a genuinely hilarious moment and we
can understand why Marvel has started casted
gifted comedians as leads in their films.
Thor The Dark World
Thor is probably one of the most ridiculous
characters in The Avengers and we wouldn’t
be surprised if Chris Hemsworth’s career
veered towards comedy once he is done playing
the Asgardian.
We have already showcased how much trouble
Thor’s hammer caused the cast and crew during
filming but it turns out that his iconic red
cape was a real troublemaker as well.
Some hilarious bloopers from the gag reel
for Thor The Dark World show Hemsworth’s
cape getting in the way by covering the face
of his scene mates and sometimes even his
own.
Each time, this wardrobe malfunction causes
everyone in the scene to start laughing and
totally break character.
This movie may not have ended up being super
fun, but it looks like the production of it
totally was!
Spiderman: Homecoming
While the world won’t get to see Spiderman
Homecoming until summer 2017, there have already
been a lot of leaked behind the scenes moments
that have assured us that being on set for
this movie must have been a blast.
Holland has already shown off his serious
acrobatic skills from his time as a gymnast
but the world went a little crazy when an
Instagram video was posted showing him break
dancing while in his Spiderman motion capture
suit.
Holland has also posted some fun pictures
of himself as Spiderman that really make it
seem like they were having a good time working
on this movie.
The first trailer for Spiderman Homecoming
set the Internet a blaze and it is definitely
one of the most anticipated movies of 2017.
The Avengers
Back in 2012, The Avengers really introduced
the world to how awesome shared movie universes
can be with their epic group film.
While this movie must have taken a tremendous
amount of work, it looks like it was also
a lot of fun to make.
After looking at the gag reel, it seems like
this star-studded cast was always in the mood
to shake it on set and the camera captured
the actors dancing around on numerous occasions.
There is footage of Chris Evans wiggling around
in his Captain America suit and even some
hilarious clips of Jeremy Renner fist pumping
with his Hawkeye attire on.
The Avengers cast has always been admired
for its on screen chemistry and it looks like
all these super powered stars get along between
takes as well!
So there’s our list of 10 Marvel movies
that show their stars having a lot of fun
on set.
Which one of these moments was your favorite?
What is your favorite Marvel movie of all
time?
Let us know in the comments section below
and be sure to subscribe to our channel for
more fun videos – like this one!